welcome back to the game's foot stage
here at e3 2016 brought to you by
airheads bites today we're gonna be
talking a little bit about the games
that are missing from this year's
conference I'm Lucy James joined by
Justin hey Walt Peter Browns
doppelganger yes we shouldn't have shot
you two next to each other of a peter
brown and alexa rae career I'm a little
uncomfortable sitting next to them okay
yeah all the bad touching guys we had
some incredible reveals yesterday and of
course the extended showing of Zelda
this morning but there are some games
that we we hoped would be here that are
not so let's talk a little bit first
we've got a haze like the studio from
the guys who made brothers a tale of two
sons announced a couple years ago that
they were working on something we saw
tease nada hmm yeah I mean like every
year like any III there are always gonna
be games that don't make it and i think
this year was more interesting in that
it felt like every press conference was
was pretty tight there wasn't a lot of
room for the extended demos and previews
or just like the quick snort short
snippet so they've done before but but
it is curious not to see something that
from the hazel aight guys because that
was to bruk tale of the two brothers
game was like so moving and emotional
yeah um we saw a little teaser trailer
where two guys were in the back of a
back of some kind of train one was
having a cigarette I have no idea what
like incubate car children the game yeah
well the brothers like that yeah I mean
one row not brothers sometime I don't
see games because they're cancelled or
because they go into limbo but I think
sometimes we just don't see them because
maybe there isn't enough to show or it's
not gonna match up with what of the
other games are seeing I think that has
to be the case with something like that
yeah for sure we also didn't see
anything from popcap a TS press
conference this year usually they were
yeah usually they have some kind of
presents I mean obviously they're kind
of moving away from the mobile but
garden warfare 2 came out of Cup a few
months ago no more DLC drops or anything
yeah I mean that game came not too long
after the first one right like I feel
like the market for a popcap console
game is saturated at the moment the
weird thing is those games are really
good like there are a lot of fun and
like yeah it shouldn't be that fun you
how defense game on iOS in it turn into
this I can totally acknowledge that but
uh yeah I I hadn't even missed it I
didn't even realize it wasn't they
weren't here it speaks more about me
then to be honest I'm always on the
lookout for something peggle okay yeah
um Oh 30 don't even if they have another
announcement to the peggle 2 and out so
it was just a guy with a mask on i would
absolutely love it but II express
Carmen's as well we didn't see anything
from criterions action game oh that
thing has to be dead like it we've it's
been long enough between when we saw
whatever it was of it that I think it's
just something I the rug that idea has
to have been folded into sleet into the
MMO extreme sports game like I I don't
think that that criterion game is in
production anymore and we know criterion
has moved on to the Star Wars stuff
which they announced during the press
conference so I don't have a lot of hope
that that's still in production no me
neither sadly but need for speed also
was not here this year um do we have any
I mean it there is a game coming out
next year but right nothing to show yea
there is a little strange on honestly um
but that game is the one that where it's
only it only takes place at night that
was the last one yes neat that was the
last one the only at night oh well it
came out um it came out it had a bunch
of um kind of masteries you could have
with very famous drivers and such like
that guy we just saw with the dreadlocks
yeah it was one of them that was the FMV
one yes they went into MFM being a bunch
seamless kind of movement do what do we
expect from them more cars and some
night landscapes isn't it gonna go back
to a kind of day and night cycle I think
I make more sense to have a racing in
the takes place at all times a day if
not just day is all strange yeah I mean
there's there are I think Forza and you
know for Surrey alee dominates the
racing space these days yes and
something like need for speed which is a
series it's been around a long time that
has a real identity issue every game
seems to struggle with defining what the
series will be as it moves forward and
this one didn't seem to catch on I don't
know that they're ready to just sort of
jump back in with another
new concept and say hey we still don't
know any for speed is so we're just
gonna throw paint in the wall and see
what sticks and I even if there is a
danger and hoping as much as we love
some franchises and games and hoping for
something too soon like I never want my
some of my favorite franchises to be
every year no matter what because you
know that's not going to be quite as
interesting as when you don't know when
the next ain't gonna come like a grand
theft auto but yeah another thing I was
quite surprised especially considering
the Scorpio announcement that we saw
nothing from crackdown yes yes crackdown
3 i've spoken about this i feel like
every time we talk about this game i go
back to the cloud-based demo that i saw
games come yeah where it was like
basically a supercomputer in the clouds
showing environments with complete
destructibility that was multiplayer it
was amazing I and they've shown that in
pieces but I can't believe they're not
showcasing that more cuz even if they
shouldn't show a show Scorpio gameplay
they were showing an xbox one that was
like an Xbox one thing that I saw i
takes place in the cloud but I can
understand they might not want to say we
have a new powerful console and the
cloud yeah so maybe they'll be saving it
for another day but that's the only
thing that really makes crackdown
interesting i think especially for the
big guys like they have to be saving
some things for gamescom right yes yeah
games comes way more on the map i guess
for announcements and it definitely used
to be i think no yeah that's grown um
it's taken the place of TGS yeah well
poor teachers um but Ubisoft it but 30th
year and no Beyond Good and Evil 2 I can
understand why they had they did have
another announcement Michelle on cell
saying it's not canceled its not not
caught up trust me she'll on cell
anymore he says yeah but I think I think
he's completely too preoccupied with
wild but she also didn't see actually
wooden ceiling from while is he okay you
know just meet a hugger oh just even
seeing this gameplay now just makes me
sad yeah but at least we know it's not
dead dead and it's not being rushed out
like yeah that you don't you don't want
to see a franchise like that also pushed
out the door to to meet a deadline yeah
and this isn't even gameplay right I
mean we were seeing a cinematic
yeah it stands to reason that the game
is evolving I do I would not rule out
beyond good and evil too i think that
that is going to happen somehow eventual
I mean Shenmue 3 came out yeah baby it's
gonna take it was an out what did you
not come out why yes so he was announced
it's gonna come out that's true what we
want but it's gonna happen beyond good
and evil two IVs not to half-life 3 it's
gonna happen oh I mean um yeah they said
he was still working on it i hope that
was kind of like a goodwill thing
because of the whole vivendi thing they
need to get people on their side yeah
over sub-sites i really hope that it
wasn't just a bit of talk i really hope
that it is still in development yeah
let's talk about sony's press conference
because there are a few things missing
from that such as everyone thought read
dead 2 would be announced there have
been a few leaks and nothing just I
can't shrug any higher like there are
rock stars gonna do its own thing like
they don't need e they don't need III
they don't need sony's press conference
they don't need anybody like they can do
something in the middle of like the
night and be like oh look right did
who's coming and like people will like
all flock to it so like i'm not
surprised so some of the rumors going
around were also that it might have been
during the pc gaming show just as they
wanted like you're not gonna watch this
anyway so we're gonna throw that in
there just to what was interesting is
there was a leaked map a few weeks ago
and it had in the bottom corner new
Bourdeaux which is obviously where mafia
three set so everyone was kind of hoping
out for some kind of I don't know how
those streams would cross but everyone
was thought sort of thought what a
stretch yeah hey yeah don't make me get
my tinfoil hat up is there a chance that
2k would ever go a route like Nintendo
do this year Nintendo I think took a
really interesting thing and just we're
gonna do one game we're going to stream
that for a locked up I mean the stream
pokemon for a while yeah went back on
their promise they said they'll have one
game and it was the other game but 2k
could totally do that they could totally
just do here's red dead we're gonna this
is our press conference it's red dead
and we're gonna play red dead for I
don't you don't need a press conference
it could just start up a Twitter stream
and go hey because sure you read did to
know yeah another missing rock star
property the people I mean it was it was
announced with a logo and I don't think
gameplays I've been seen but agent then
stuff from the sounds of it it was going
to be some kind of you know secret spy
action adventure is it dead dead dead no
I don't think it's dead i think i will
hundred percent think it's dead rockstar
releases games when they're ready they
do they take that whole blizzard and
valve approach yeah and if they feel
like the game is something that they can
put out like I think that's when they'll
see it when will see it like they
definitely don't adhere to a schedule no
they're rock stars yeah so then the
PlayStation 3 exclusive like the time
has passed that's gonna be a temptation
for my CRT my position to excuse terms
mr. dead or at least maybe the ideas are
being folded into something else mmm
like my last guardian to a couple of
surprising emissions from sony's press
conference as well first of all with
dreams media molecules I still don't
know what that game is thank your
simulator games have you seen the bear
it's really scary he's like kind of
being controlled with a mite that's the
guys molecule yeah it does seem really
cool but I just I don't know what it is
I think that scares me a little I have
to imagine I have to imagine it's being
retooled for VR I think the promise of
that game is lost just on a on a screen
especially after playing something like
tilt brush on HTC vive which lets you
paint in 3d space mm-hmm you know it's
similar to what you're doing here very
you know exactly the same but that said
it is a very powerful experience you be
able to paint around yourself in VR and
have these things last so I you know
this would be a great showcase for
PlayStation VR and hey what if it's
bundled in what if it's not as the
product is going to be sold in itself
it's literally a way to get people to
just really embrace and become embedded
in a virtual experience and you're not
trying to create a game that does that
you're giving them the tools to make
their own thing yeah so I think it would
be smart if that's what they're doing
and because it is tools like I I could
see them being wary of showing too much
before it's ready because it this could
be incredibly unintuitive while they are
optimizing it while they're getting it
ready because the developer is used to
it they're like I can show this off and
make this look good and we'll work on
tweaking the way it works later yeah but
I don't know another another very
strange mission giving that it's coming
out in a few weeks no one sky which has
been a
real kind of it's often taken center
stage when it's been shown in sony's
press conferences and nothing i feel
like for them it was a great token to
showcase like we have a game that's
unlike anything else that is out there
right it's sort of one of one of a kind
but now here we are having seen the same
thing year after year yeah a bit long in
the tooth there's things that they can't
share because they don't want to spoil
the experience and with the game coming
out soon and with the the hyper on the
pre-order and the original date
announcement people are they've already
kind of made up their mind I think I
don't think Sony needs that feather in
their cap anymore no um but I think
overall though I'm kind of glad that
there were a bunch of new and I'll smith
new things as you can sink our teeth
into but guys thank you so much for
joining me for more coverage from e3
2016 make sure you stay tuned to
gamespot com